ce que vous voyez juste ici c'est la
péninsule de Corée deux jours vu de
l'espace et ça vous l'aurez deviné c'est
la même péninsule de Corée mais donc la
nuit deux jours donc impossible de
discerner que la péninsule de Corée
abrite en fait deux États mais la nuit
est bien la différence éclate la Corée
du Nord ou l'électricité n'est pas aussi
développée disparaît de la carte seule
la Corée du Sud reste visible une
péninsule donc et deux pays je ne vous
apprends rien d'un côté la Corée du Sud
l'un des pays les plus riches au monde
la vingtième économie mondiale où sont
produits des téléphones des voitures et
des télévisions pour le monde entier
avec des liens importants avec
l'Occident et notamment les États-Unis
et de l'autre côté la Corée du Nord un
pays beaucoup plus isolé là aussi c'est
évident je ne vous apprends rien avec
une pauvreté aujourd'hui plus importante
et avec à sa tête le dirigeant Kim
jumoon mais alors comment en est-on
arrivé là pourquoi y a-t-il aujourd'hui
de Corée et bien c'est l'histoire
passionnante que l'on va voir
aujourd'hui bienvenue au passage à tous
les nouveaux qui suivent la chaîne ces
derniers jours mais avant de commencer
rapidement je tiens à remercier nordvpn
qui nous soutient une nouvelle fois sur
cette nouvelle vidéo vous le savez
nordvpn vous permet de changer
d'emplacement virtuel un petit peu
partout dans le monde parmi 59 pays
disponibles c'est très pratique mais
vous voyagez par exemple pour vos études
votre travail ou encore pour le plaisir
en vacances c'est pratique déjà parce
que vous allez pouvoir faire des
économistes sur vos réservations que ce
soit sur les vols les hôtels ou encore
les locations de voitures en localisant
votre connexion Internet dans votre pays
de destination où les prix sont souvent
plus avantageux par ailleurs c'est
pratique parce que vous allez pouvoir
continuer d'avoir accès à vos contenus
préférés à l'étranger des contenus qui
peuvent parfois être géo bloqués en vous
géolocalisant donc toujours en France et
puis vous allez pouvoir protéger
davantage vos données ou que vous soyez
en un clic grâce au chiffrement de votre
connexion Internet et grâce à leur
protection anti menaces qui permet de
lutter lutter contre les virus et les
logiciels malveillants bref encore un
grand merci à nordvpn pour leur soutien
n'hésitez pas à checker le lien qui
s'affiche à l'écran actuellement et que
je vous mets aussi en description il
vous permet de bénéficier de quatre mois
gratuits sur tout abonnement de 2 ans en
plus tu ne remise exclusive et c'est
satisfait ou remboursé durant les 30
premiers jours voilà vous avez tout on
est parti désormais avec la vidéo
[Musique]
alors beaucoup l'ignore mais la Corée du
Nord et la Corée du Sud sont encore
officiellement en guerre et c'est le cas
depuis quelques temps puisqu'ils sont en
guerre depuis
1953 et oui la guerre de Corée qui a
opposé la Corée du Nord à la Corée du
Sud entre 1950 et 1953 on va en parler
d'ailleurs dans quelques instants mais
cette guerre elle n'est toujours pas
terminée en fait les combats se sont
certes arrêtés grâce à un cessez-le-feu
en 1953 ça c'est le feu c'est donc un
arrêt provisoire des combats mais il n'y
a toujours pas eu d'accord de paix près
de 70 ans plus tard et alors qu'on
commémore justement en 2023 les 70 ans
de se sucer le feu et bien la région
craint une reprise des combats en effet
ces derniers mois la Corée du Nord qui
s'estime en danger multiplie les
lancements de missiles hostile des
missiles menaçant à la fois la Corée du
Sud le Japon ou encore les États-Unis et
face à cette armement nord-coréen
progressif la Corée du Sud s'estime
aussi menacé et elle a engagé un grand
plan de défense avec son allié
historique maintenant les États-Unis
bref des tensions importantes ces
derniers mois et pourtant regardez cette
image c'était il y a pas si longtemps on
avril 2018 cette photo a été prise au
seul et unique point de passage qui
existe aujourd'hui entre les deux Corées
à la frontière des limitée par ce petit
muret ce point de passage se situe au
cœur même de ce que l'on appelle la zone
des militarisée entre les deux Corées
une sorte de zone tampon entre les deux
pays et sur cette photo donc en 2018 le
président sud-coréen de l'époque munjah
in et le leader nord-coréen Kim Jong-Un
posait pour une poignée de main
historique la première poignée de main
entre les dirigeants des deux pays
depuis 1953 et ce fameux cessez-le-feu
de la guerre de Corée et c'est
d'ailleurs à ce même endroit que
quelques mois plus tard Kim Jong-un
avait posé de manière tout aussi
historique avec le le président
américain Donald Trump un Donald Trump
déterminé à ce que les États-Unis
réengagent un dialogue avec la Corée du
Nord cette zone des militarisée
surnommée DMZ en anglais vous en avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler c'est
peut-être la zone la plus sécurisée au
monde aujourd'hui elle fait 250 km de
long et 4 km de large elle sépare la
Corée du Nord de la Corée du Sud et elle
n'a vraiment de démilétariser que le nom
on estime que en raison de la guerre de
Corée il y a encore plus d'un million de
mines dans la zone et tout au long de
cette zone il y a aussi évidemment des
milliers de soldats qui surveillent la
frontière entre les deux pays et partout
tout le long des murs des barbelés des
souterrains des mirador et donc désarmés
bref pour résumer un cessez le feu un
calme très relatif et pas d'accord de
paix mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
pendant longtemps il n'y avait qu'une
seule Corée alors ce drapeau ne vous dit
peut-être rien alors qu'il faut l'avouer
il est quand même plutôt stylé il faut
savoir qu'en fait jusqu'en 1897 c'était
le drapeau du royaume de Corée celui
donc d'une seule et même Corée et oui
jusqu'en 1897 la Corée était donc un
pays unifié un pays d'ailleurs d'une
très grande stabilité puisque de 1392 à
1897 il a été gouverné par la même
dynastie la dynastie des diocéans alors
ce royaume de Corée a certes parfois été
sous l'influence de l'empire de Chine
mais elle a toujours eu sa propre
identité sa propre langue tradition ou
encore régime politique et d'ailleurs
pour la petite histoire à la fin du 19e
la Corée va même acquérir un surnom à
l'étranger the land of the morning calme
donc le pays du matin calme un nom
trouvé en 1886 par l'américain Percival
l'OL alors je sais au vu des tensions
aujourd'hui et de l'éclatement de la
Corée en deux tout cela paraît bien loin
mais alors comment en est-on arrivé
jusque là
et bien 500 ans d'absolu stabilité vont
prendre fin au début du 20ème siècle à
l'époque en fait le Japon se développe
énormément se construit une très grande
armée prend le contrôle de la Chine en
1895 attaque la Russie en 1905 et finit
également par attaquer la Corée et
finalement et bien grand bouleversement
la Corée fini par être totalement
colonisé en 1910 la Corée va alors
rester une colonie japonaise jusqu'au 2
septembre
1945 ce jour-là notamment après avoir
été frappé par deux bombes atomiques
américaines à Hiroshima et Nagasaki et
bien le Japon capitule et la deuxième
guerre mondiale prend fin mais alors
vous allez me dire que devient à ce
moment-là la Corée avec le Japon qui
capitule en 1945 et bien après la
capitulation du Japon les États-Unis
vont proposer à l'URSS une sorte de
pacte
occupée chacun militairement une partie
de la Corée l'URSS va donc prendre le
contrôle du Nord et les États-Unis vont
prendre le contrôle du Sud pour les
Etats-Unis cette situation leur permet à
l'époque d'éviter que les Soviétiques
contrôlent l'ensemble de la péninsule
coréenne et on va donc que déjà à
l'époque la question de l'influence de
ces pays dans la région étaient déjà
très importantes alors pour tracer la
frontière et créer deux zones à peu près
égales les États-Unis proposent de faire
au plus simple en utilisant la 38e
parallèle et parallèle c'est donc des
lignes imaginaires dont le tracé est
parallèle à l'équateur des lignes
utilisées en géographie pour situer les
endroits sur la planète alors dans ces
deux nouvelles Corées chaque camp va
installer un gouvernement qui lui est
favorable en Corée du Sud les Etats-Unis
vont donc renverser le gouvernement en
place et installer un vieux leader
anti-communiste singmany au nord l'URSS
favorise un régime communiste dirigé par
qui ils sont l'Organisation des Nations
Unies valide alors par cette partition
mais l'idée c'est que ce découpage entre
les deux camps soit temporaire pour 5
ans et que la Corée soit de nouveau uni
quelques années plus tard en 1950 alors
spoiler vous l'aurez compris ça ne s'est
pas du tout passé comme prévu en fait
les tensions entre les gouvernements
deviennent de plus en plus fortes chacun
commence à revendiquer qu'il est la
vérité en 1948 chaque État se proclame
indépendant et le 25 juin 1950 et bien
tout bascule
[Musique]
le 25 juin 1950 l'armée nord-coréenne
franchit le 38e parallèle et envahit la
Corée du Sud les 200 000 soldats de la
Corée du Nord sont lourdement équipés
par l'URSS notamment avec des chars en
deux jours ils prennent donc Séoul la
capitale du Sud et puis rapidement ils
écrasent les sud-coréens et prennent le
contrôle de 90% du pays l'armée
sud-coréenne pourtant soutenue par
quelques milliers de soldats américains
et donc encerclé à Busan au sud-est de
la péninsule à ce moment là retournement
de situation dans ce contexte de début
de guerre froide les États-Unis ne
veulent absolument pas laisser tomber la
Corée du Sud aux mains de l'URSS ils
vont donc lancer les négociations avec
l'Organisation des Nations Unies pour
monter une opération militaire commune
avec 20 autres pays et aider donc ainsi
la Corée du Sud le 27 juin 1950 donc
l'ONU qui vient d'être créé après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et dont le rôle
est de garant considère la paix dans le
monde décide d'adopter la résolution 83
cette résolution recommande aux membres
de l'Organisation des Nations Unies de
venir en aide à la Corée du Sud et donc
début juillet une nouvelle résolution la
résolution 84 ouvre la voie à une
opération militaire commune avec
plusieurs pays de l'ONU pour tenter de
rétablir la paix c'est la naissance du
commandement des Nations Unies en Corée
dirigée par les États-Unis et dont on va
faire partie la France avec un millier
de soldats français c'est le début là
aussi d'une offensive absolument
historique puisque le 15 septembre 1950
à 6h30 du matin les troupes sont mandats
de l'ONU mais mené par le général
américain McArthur débarque par la mer
en Corée du Nord ils prennent par
surprise l'armée nord-coréenne il ne
débarque pas à buzanne donc oui encerclé
l'armée sud-coréenne 1000 décide donc
plutôt d'attaquer par surprise et
d'attaquer par le nord-ouest de la Corée
du Sud près de 5 ans après la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
le monde entier se retrouve à prendre
part à une nouvelle guerre dans cette
petite péninsule de Corée les forces
menées par les Américains prennent
rapidement le dessus sur les forces
nord-coréennes pour reprendre la Corée
du Nord mais en fait elles vont pas
s'arrêter là simplement reprendre la
Corée du Sud en fait c'est force menées
par ce général américain vont franchir
le 38e parallèle ils vont donc bien
envahir la Corée du Nord prendre le
contrôle de la capitale Pyongyang et
aller jusqu'à atteindre la frontière
chinoise bref pour résumer beaucoup de
combat mais on est passé en deux mois
d'une situation où la Corée du Nord et
les Soviétiques contrôlaient
l'intégralité de la péninsule à une
situation complètement renversée ou
désormais c'est les forces de l'ONU
menées par les Américains qui ont repris
le contrôle de la péninsule hors de
façon tout aussi spectaculaire et bien
nouveau retournement de situation peu de
temps après la Corée du Nord va être
aidé par la Chine la Chine va mobiliser
près de 3 millions de soldats pour
reprendre donc du terrain en 1951 la
situation va finir par se stabiliser
justement à nouveau au niveau de ce 38e
parallèle mais pour autant les combats
ne vont pas cesser avec notamment des
milliers de bombardements américains
particulièrement destructeurs sur la
Corée du Nord des bombardements
américains y compris au napalm une
substance conçue pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en 1942 et qui provoque
des incendies et d'énormes dégâts en
Corée du Nord finalement le 27 juillet
1953 la Corée du Nord la Corée du Sud la
Chine et les États-Unis signent un
cessez le feu pour mettre fin au combat
à court terme c'est donc ce fameux
cessez-le-feu dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure qui est encore en vigueur
aujourd'hui alors cette guerre de Corée
est assez méconnue en Europe et pourtant
elle est absolument historique à
plusieurs titres déjà c'est le seul et
unique conflit de la guerre froide ou
des soldats américains ont combattu
directement contre des soldats
soviétiques ensuite c'est à ce jour pour
le seul conflit de l'histoire ou des
soldats américains ont combattu
directement contre des soldats chinois
il faut noter par ailleurs donc qu'il y
a des soldats français qui ont participé
à cette guerre de Corée ils étaient
commandés par le général Raoul magrain
Vernerie surnommé Monclar qui était à
l'époque un véritable héros national en
France et qui a surpris l'armée
américaine par l'efficacité de son
bataillon bref les combats ont été
extrêmement violents mais cette guerre
de Corée n'a pas modifié les frontières
entre les deux Corées puisqu'on est
finalement revenus au point de départ
avec ce 38e parallèle cette guerre a par
contre profondément ravagée les
relations entre les deux pays en fait
notamment avec l'intervention des pays
étrangers elle a été d'une brutalité
extrême au moins 3 millions de morts
dont 2 millions de morts qui n'étaient
pas des militaires et on retrouve
tristement des crimes contre l'humanité
et des massacres organisés des deux
côtés et finalement cette guerre a créé
une haine très forte entre la Corée du
Nord et la Corée du Sud une haine qui va
renforcer la séparation entre les deux
pays alors que moins de 10 ans
auparavant ils auraient pu être unis et
bien le contexte général de cette guerre
froide entre américain et russe a
participé à une escalade meurtrière il y
a une séparation assez stricte entre les
deux pays
alors comment les deux Corées sont
devenus si différents en Corée du Nord
en fait il y a un homme qui va changer
véritablement le destin du pays c'est
lui qui mitsoung et si vous lui trouvez
un air familier c'est peut-être normal
c'est en fait le grand-père de l'actuel
leader nord-coréen Kim Jong-Un il avait
initialement été installé donc au
pouvoir par l'URSS mais il va mettre
dans toutes les têtes que les problèmes
du pays viennent de puissance extérieure
en fait c'est véritablement lui qui va
construire une forme de haine vis-à-vis
de plusieurs puissances extérieures
évidemment avec les États-Unis en tête
il va aussi construire un pouvoir très
autoritaire en Corée du Nord et si qui
song réussi à construire une nation ou
en tout cas une forme d'identité
nationale avec ce récit là bien il
échoue à transformer l'économie et à la
fin des années 80 l'effondrement de
l'URSS ce qui était son principal allié
plongent le pays dans une très grave
crise et de 1994 à 1997 la Corée du Nord
être frappé par une énorme famine une
famine qui a provoqué la mort de près de
2 millions d'habitants là aussi une
autre période de l'histoire souvent
méconnue mais pourtant très grave et
crucial pour la Corée du Nord c'est
alors que pour garder la main Kim
Jong-il qui a succédé à son père prend
un nouveau virage celui du développement
d'armes nucléaire et de missiles
balistique de 2006 à 2017 la Corée du
Nord va notamment mener 6 essais
nucléaires ça c'est donc du côté de la
Corée du Nord mais du côté de la Corée
du Sud un homme va aussi beaucoup
changer les choses il s'agit de partout
en fait quand on part tchoumi prend le
pouvoir en 1961 le pays est parmi les
plus pauvres au monde et parking réforme
complètement l'état il va adopter une
stratégie très différente de la Corée du
Nord lui va décider d'ouvrir son pays
vers l'extérieur et vers le capitalisme
il va donc restructurer complètement
l'économie en transformant des grandes
entreprises familiales comme les tables
en forçant en fait ces entreprises à
devenir plus grande et à s'ouvrir à de
nouveaux secteurs ces entreprises
aujourd'hui vous les connaissez
forcément on peut parler de Samsung ou
encore LG et au passage le poids de ces
entreprises dans l'économie sud-coréenne
est absolument considérable c'est assez
hallucinant et je pense d'ailleurs qu'on
pourra en faire l'objet d'une vidéo un
jour en quelques dizaines d'années on
assiste donc à ce que certains appellent
le miracle économique coréen entre 1961
et 2021 le PIB par habitant est passé de
92 dollars à 36000 dollars soit une
multiplication par près de 400 en 60 ans
ça c'est sur le plan économique mais sur
le plan politique parking mène une
répression sanglante contre toutes les
personnes soupçonnées de communisme
attisant donc encore plus les tensions
avec la Corée du Nord et en 1979 il est
finalement assassiné à priori par les
États-Unis qui était visiblement
embarrassé par cette répression des
États-Unis devenu donc plus que mon
soucieux des droits de l'homme et c'est
d'ici que elle va commencer le processus
de démocratisation de la Corée du Sud
mais alors avec ces deux Corées si
différentes aujourd'hui une question
forcément se pose une réunification
est-elle encore possible aujourd'hui
et bien regardez cette image nous sommes
au Jeux olympiques d'été de Sydney en
2000 les équipes de Corée du Nord et de
Corée du Sud défilent alors ensemble
lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture sous le
même drapeau celui de la Corée unie on a
observé une image similaire aux JO
d'Athènes en 2004 aux JO d'hiver en 2006
à Turin ou encore lors des Jeux
olympiques d'hiver de 2018 disputés à
pyongchang en Corée du Sud cette année
là les équipes de hockey masculine et
féminine des deux pays sont même venus à
s’unir et à faire une seule et même
équipe de hockey sur glace chez les
hommes comme chez les femmes
représentant donc la Corée unie lors de
cette compétition alors forcément ça
avait donné lieu à des scènes très
fortes en émotion regardez par exemple
ces images de l'accueil des Nord-Coréens
par les joueuses sud-coréennes avec des
échanges de bouquets de fleurs et ces
autres images aussi à la fin de la
compétition avec des Hokage
nord-coréennes disons au revoir en
larmes à leur partenaire coréenne il
faut dire que malgré toutes ces tensions
c'est de pays ont quand même beaucoup
d'éléments culturels en commun il y a
encore des très grandes similarités
entre les langues et ce même si la
langue en Corée du Sud a évolué quand
même au fil des années influencer
notamment par l'arrivée de l'anglais et
l'influence des États-Unis mais pourtant
donc malgré ses rapprochements qui
pourraient être possible et qu'on a pu
observer symboliquement à plusieurs
reprises et bien les tensions restent
donc très importantes en fait ça fait
des décennies que il y a des tentatives
au Nord comme au Sud d'essayer
d'améliorer les relations bilatérales il
y a notamment une offensive extrêmement
importante à la fin des années 90 le
Président Kim De Jong à l'époque mais en
avance qu'on appelle la politique du
rayon de soleil il obtient d'ailleurs le
prix Nobel de la paix en 2001 pour cela
mais ça le rapprochement va être de
courte durée puisque la Corée du Nord va
se nucléariser premier essai en 2006 et
puis surtout les incidents et les
provocations nord-cores vont reprendre
il faut se rappeler quand 2010 la Corée
du Nord elle a coulé un navire
sud-coréen qui plus de 40 morts elle a
bombardé une île sud-coréenne où il y a
eu quatre morts dont deux civils et donc
on est depuis en permanence dans une
forme de yoyo avec des rapprochements
limités des périodes de fortes tension
on est actuellement dans une période de
tension et le dernier approchement qu'il
a de 2018 qui avait des bruits débouchés
et ça c'était exceptionnel en l'espace
de quelques mois sur trois sommets entre
Kim Jong-un et moonjean aujourd'hui ces
trois rencontres elles m'ont débouchées
sur rien de concret et ainsi aujourd'hui
l'espoir d'une réunification entre les
deux Corées pareil quand même très
illusoire aujourd'hui il faut être très
clair la question de la réunification
elle ne se pose pas et la question d'une
réunification agréée entre les deux pays
elle se pose encore moins le scénario
évidemment en Corée du Sud c'est
d'imaginer une fusion du Nord dans le
sud et une transformation du Nord sur le
modèle du feu évidemment les dirigeants
de nord-coréen souhaiteraient l'inverse
et donc un accord politique entre les
deux pays pour qu'il y a une
réunification aujourd'hui c'est un
accord qui est tout simplement il faut
le reconnaître totalement impossible
alors on s'est longtemps posé la
question d'un potentiel effondrement du
régime nord-coréen un petit peu sur le
modèle de ce qui s'est passé en
Allemagne de l'Est au début des années
90 mais aujourd'hui ce scénario il
semble extrêmement peu probable malgré
les sanctions internationales malgré la
fermeture du pays à cause du covid le
régime nord-coréen il tient et donc la
question de la réunification aujourd'hui
très honnêtement ne se pose pas voilà
j'espère en tout cas que cette vidéo
vous aura permis d'y voir plus clair
pour la petite histoire d'ailleurs
j'avais réalisé un reportage en 2019 en
Corée du Sud justement sur le sujet en
fait j'avais été rencontré un réfugié
nord-coréen qui avait fui la Corée du
Nord et qui était partie vivre en Corée
du Sud c'était passionnant parce qu'en
fait au delà de du récit de son trajet
de la Corée du Nord à la Corée du Sud
qui forcément était très périlleux et
bien il raconte à quel point il y a des
différences culturelles très fortes
entre les deux pays et à quel point en
fait le plus dur à quasiment été pour
lui l'intégration au sein de la Corée du
Sud que réellement cette fuite de la
Corée du Nord donc si vous voulez voir
cette vidéo je vous mets le lien en
description je vous préviens d'avance
cet effet il y a quelques années j'avais
pas la même tête j'avais une voix assez
insupportable mais sinon vous avez le
courage et bien n'hésitez pas par
ailleurs je fais cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner évidemment
pour ne pas rater les vidéos suivantes
ces derniers jours on essaie d'alterner
des formats d'interviews de différentes
personnalités avec d'autres formats des
formats de reportages des formats de
décryptage bref j'espère en tout cas que
tout ça vous plaît enfin je tiens à
remercier Antoine mondaz qui est donc
chercheur à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique à Paul qui est
journaliste au sein de l'équipe et qui a
travaillé avec moi à l'écriture de cette
vidéo et enfin aller au qui est sur le
montage dernière petite chose mais je
pense que vous le savez pour suivre
l'actualité au quotidien ça se passe sur
notre chaîne YouTube que je vous mets
directement en description mon poste une
vidéo par jour écoutez je crois que j'ai
tout dit prenez soin de vous prenez vos
proches et puis on se dit à très vite